people have have
gotten a lot more comfort with advisors
and people online
and they can kind of quickly figure out
who knows what they
what they know and you know the the the
higher end clients also have teams of
advisors
so they quickly can kind of separate the
the wannabes from those who really know
what they're doing and i'm not saying
i'm a genius but if you do anything for
three plus decades
you get pretty good at it what have you
noticed as a general trend with
um these people that are leaving
canada you know the united states and
moving themselves to these countries
um that purportedly will treat them
better on the
tax levels like is there a common theme
that you've noticed in their lives
sure so so one of the things to
understand is the
revenue model of a progressive tax
system whether you think it's fair or
not
what ends up happening is the top one
percent account for
anywhere from a third to 40 percent of
the total tax revenue
so the government needs money if you run
any type of business and
and one out of 100 of your customers is
bringing in a third to
40 percent of your revenue you kind of
want to know about those customers
well if you think of those customers
they are people
who much more tend to be location
independent
they can run their business from
they don't have to be standing on the
shop for overlooking somebody
um they have skills etc which they can
either
put online or they can manage their
money online and so they're much
less sticky from a business point of
view the result is
you only need a small number of those
golden geese as we call them
to leave to have a huge negative
asymmetric impact
on the total tax revenue that they
that the subtitle of our book was how
the one percent
affect the 99 percent well you only need
a small number of the one percent to
leave
to leave a huge hole in you know the
the government revenues for those left
behind
and that's so the trend i've really seen
is that people are
are really discovering their mobility
um we've probably all seen the kind of
little map of manhattan like the center
of the world
and you know a few bridge and tunnels
over to new jersey and the rest of the
world's kind of very small
and you had people whether they were in
manhattan or toronto or
london or silicon valley who had very
you know cultivated lives they really
lived within five square blocks they
went to the same
restaurants they went to the same work
they you know socialized with the same
people they had the same amusements
and they they couldn't really dream of
overcoming this life inertia
well kovid came in and they were kind of
kicked out of town one step ahead of
covet and they were sitting up there in
the hamptons or somewhere else
and sitting there going listening to the
new york city mayor race and they're all
talking about how they're going to crank
up the
the tax rate there or people are sitting
and listening to
you know mr trudeau and his deputy prime
minister
who wrote a book called plutocrats
christian freeland
and you know the equivalents in
different different other countries
and they started saying what's wrong by
the way
sorry what's that what's that book about
by the way i've not heard of it
plutocrats yeah it's christian freeland
talking about how the rich are ruining
the world for the rest of us oh okay so
it's rich's fault again
of course yeah um and so
you know so these people are sitting
there saying well you know
honey um our favorite restaurant there's
this thing called ubereats they'll
deliver it to our door
and there's this you know google teams
and zoom and skype and
you know we've got out of manhattan and
the world didn't collapse and
you know like we can actually reproduce
our lifestyle and
now i've got this the distance that i'm
listening to what
you know now the frog has jumped out of
the water and they're now it's going
that's pretty hot water i don't know if
i want to go back in
yeah and so then they start thinking
about okay well we've already got a
place in florida let's relocate to
florida
so that's where you see you've seen the
max exodus of people the high-end people
from
new york who went went to florida and
new york city
has a city surtax and so it's seen a 40
drop in their projections for tax
revenues
simply because some of the people have
have picked up and moved to florida
and you'll get and one of the key things
to understand today is
you need to really do it i've had some
people saying well you know
i'm not really going to move to florida
but they'll never know and then i'll say
you do have a cell phone right yeah
that's pinging off a tower
every second or so and they know exactly
where you're at
i mean just like the visitors to the uh
the capitol on january 6th the police
figured out where they were at well
they're going to figure out you know
that you're standing in new york at
going to your favorite bodega
buying you know your milk and cookies
um so they're very good and the onus is
on you
to prove that you've moved to florida
it's not on the on the tax authorities
to move that
to prove that you haven't left new york
and so
that's where you need proper kind of
advice you need to execute
but the opportunities are tremendous
because people can
much more reproduce their lifestyle
independent of a specific
location than they could in the past
yeah it's
you know it's bizarre to me i i'm glad
that you mentioned that point about
like how much of an impact it has in the
tax system when
high net worth individuals just pick up
and move and
just take everything with them to
another place because that because that
does affect
the less fortunate folk because there's
less money to
um i guess steal from the rich and give
to the poor sort of thing
how what kind of effect does that have
on the economy
like over the longer term oh a huge
effect
you have to look at um if we look at
canada australia the uk for example all
of those jurisdictions have a vat tax at
gst
hst the united states is not so the
united states
when you look at the total kind of pie
of their government revenue they don't
have that vat
wedge so that's why the united states
it's actually even higher
a greater dependence so you just need a
much smaller number
to leave and they've got a huge impact
so when you have people like elizabeth
warren
who are saying well you know we're not
is the the rhetoric move from
let's get money for good stuff to let's
take money from bad
people well you know
that doesn't go over very well at the
negotiating table and
many of my clients are sitting there
saying yeah i can contribute more
i will but you know when you start the
conversation with selling beer mugs
saying billionaires tears
that's not a very productive
conversation so thank you very much i'm
going to leave
and and i will decide what's going to
happen to that money whether
to lifestyle whether to my children
whether to use strategic philanthropy
i mean it was very revealing this past
week when propublica produced his stuff
they asked warren buffett and he said
well of course it makes more sense for
me to give it to a charity than to
give it to the u.s government
you